good morning belief nation today's
message is make a better future over to
you mo head ultron don't look at the
company as a place we you generate money
you become an anaerobic who generates
money year after year this is not the
objective of life the objective of life
is to help to help the human belief in
what you are doing believe in yourself
and all of us will make a matter better
future so for those of you who've been
on my channel for more than a week you
know this is a message that I highly
rate with it's not just about making
money it's about having an impact and
making the world a better place and by
doing that you'll make a lot of money
for those of you who don't know who
Mohit I'll try it is he's a French
billionaire who recently won the world
Entrepreneur of the Year award so the
guy knows what he's talking about and if
you're an entrepreneur right now trying
to figure out how to stay alive and make
some money maybe your focus should be on
how to make the world a better place
instead of what opportunity can bring in
money immediately
so my question today for you guys today
is how do you make you make the world a
better place leave in the comments below
I'm gonna join in the discussion thank
you so much for watching
continue to believe have an amazing day
and I'll see you again tomorrow morning
for another shot events press
I spray so keep me going